Maya Angelou once said a solitary
fantasy can transform a million
realities what dream or vision do you
want to turn into reality I always
wanted to go into business for myself I
could be a consultant I'm going to go
gluten-free right after I eat that last
piece of chocolate cake you know one day
I'm gonna stand up to that crabby boss I
look good on paper I should feel great I
just know there's more you know it
because you feel it you lie awake at
night you talk about your dreams with
your partner and your friends but more
often than not you continue to do those
same behaviors that keep you from making
the change you ask yourself how can I
make it happen
research shows the odds against you
making a change in your life nine to one
nine to one even if you're facing a
life-threatening illness but let me show
you how to beat those odds you can live
the life you desire it's right there in
front of you but in order to achieve it
you must first see it then believe it
and then you must graciously ask and
train your brain to help you execute
your vision so how do we see our vision
through a picture a picture can create
movements a picture
can unite nations a picture can pull it
your heart and fill you with a deep
desire to do something at Roche
pharmaceutical the president asked us to
create a picture of his vision prior to
having one less than 40% of the
employees understood the company's
vision and strategy after seeing this
picture 96 percent understood it and 84
percent understood how what they did
every day aligned to that picture so how
can you use a picture to get what you
want by simply drawing one you don't
have to be an artist or know how to draw
as naive as your drawings might be when
you draw where you are your current
state and where you want to be your
desired new reality suddenly you have a
roadmap for change so what is your
current state well let's say you're Joe
Joe has a good job Joe
has a lovely wife Amy Joe makes good
money but like many of us Joe wants more
from life and he'd like to get rid of a
couple of things maybe that intense
workload maybe that negative boss maybe
Joe has a higher purpose he's just not
sure how to get there so now Joe's
current state is visual we remember
things better when they're attached to a
picture
65% better to be exact so now let's
imagine that Joe wants to change
something in his current state he wants
to build that desired new reality that
he dreams about in order
for Joe to freely dream he must first
trick his brain because the left side of
your brain as you know houses the critic
who is forever trying to keep you safe
from harm make sure you don't do
anything dangerous or stupid so let's
have Joe tell the critic he's just going
to use his imagination using your
imagination
activates the right side of your brain
which makes you creative and filled with
possibility so now let's dream Joe's new
life in the best case scenario one year
from today what is Joe's life like Hey
Joe has a new job
awright Joe has a new boss himself Joe
has a couple of great collaborators and
Joe is just bursting with creativity and
ideas and all of those things we dream
about connections and purpose and
freedom and love now I'm drawing this
picture as a favor to Joe today but in
real life he'd have to draw his own
picture because he can't afford me
actually because you get the most power
when you paint your own picture so now
Joe has his drawing so now he's got to
soak it in he has to fill it with color
he has to fill it with emotion he has to
get inside of it as if he's on the
inside looking out your brain actually
emits serotonin and oxytocin when you
draw and dream so you feel happy
capable creative you feel cool so now we
have Joe's current state and Joe's
desired new reality so how can Joe get
from here to there in just three bold
steps three bold steps if I knew how to
get from here to there in three bold
steps I would have done it twenty-five
years ago when I had a mullet here's
where the magic begins your brain knows
you
it's cataloged everything you've ever
seen heard experienced real or imagined
you just have to ask it to put the
pieces together for you it's as simple
as that we live in a three-dimensional
world but the light falls on the retina
in a two-dimensional fashion and the
brain it has to cope with it so how does
it deal with this extra dimension it
guesses it guesses and just as it can
guess where your cup of coffee is when
it goes to pick it up it can correctly
guess what the three bold steps are that
you should take all you have to do is
look at your picture and then close your
eyes this allows the brain to to recycle
what it sees and reconstruct it add to
it everything you've ever seen hurt
experienced or fantasized about and then
it will serve you up with the best
possible solution if you just relax and
you ask it now what's the boldest thing
I could do to get from here to there
boom immediately it will tell you see it
believe it act on it now the danger is
if any of those three bold steps are too
scary
this instinctual rational side of your
brain is going to try to talk you out of
this no no I don't want to do that
oh that desk it's not too small my legs
aren't cramped under there
Oh 20,000 a year oh that's a decent
salary Oh that boss he's not that mean
to me you know what I'm just gonna stay
right here I feel really comfortable
here
so how can you get yourself to do the
boldest thing by drawing the most
compelling picture so when you look here
you're in pain it hurts when you're here
you're ecstatic it's fantastic you're
already living inside that connected and
free life you drew so every day you get
up you soak in your picture you step
into the possibility and this is the
most important part you act on it you do
one small thing you call up that friend
you know who started her own business
you ask her how did you do it you ask
Amy will you support me in my vision you
go to your boss and you ask him for a
raise and you become that one person out
of ten to make change happen now I put
this template on your chair so that you
could do for yourself what I just did
for Joe you've seen some fantastic ideas
today that have inspired your dream I
dare you to draw that dream into that
template I double dare you to choose a
symbol in your drawing that represents
that desired new reality take a picture
of it with your phone and send it to us
at TEDx Rainier Maya Angelou said a
solitary fantasy can transform a million
realities just three bold steps can
transform one reality yours thank you
you